[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Mitri Sirin einen schönen guten Abend
rudi zerne hat heute den sonntagssport
hallo schönen guten Abend dann blicken
wir gemeinsam auf unsere
Themen
Bodenoffensive hat noch nicht begonnen
das israelische Militär wartet auf die
Entscheidung der Politik
Polen vor Richtungsentscheidung bei der
Parlamentswahl gibt es ein enges Rennen
zwischen Regierung und
Opposition und erfolgreiches Debüt das
dfbteam gewinnt das erste Spiel unter
Trainer
nagelsmann
nahosteskalation Tag 9 Iran droht und
warnt Erzfeind Israel vor einer
Bodenoffensive im Gazastreifen China und
Ägypten mahnen dass palästinensische
Zivilisten geschützt werden müssten und
drängen auf einen Waffenstillstand
unabhängig davon hat Israel seinen
geplanten truppeneinmarsch noch nicht
begonnen dennoch die Lage bleibt höchst
angespannt Peter
Böhmer tiefgekühlte Leichen in Lastwagen
gelagert Rafa im Gazastreifen direkt an
der ägyptischen Grenze der Krieg
schreibt seine brutalen
geschichtenenen diesen Kühllast dann
stapeln weil die Leichenhallen voll sind
schau dir das an da haben wir noch Platz
und hier ist schon alles voll makabre
Worte in einer Wirklichkeit die viele
Menschen traumatisieren wird eine Schule
der Vereinten Nationen in der Nähe ist
voller Flüchtlinge die allerdings schon
hier waren bevor die israelischen
Streitkräfte die Menschen aufgefordert
haben den Norden zu verlassen auf Druck
der USA soll hier im Süden Gazas aber
inzwischen das Wasser wieder fließen das
es tagelang nicht gab Strom allerdings
bleibt offenbar abgestellt die Armee
veröffentlichte heute diese Aufnahmen
sie sollen zeigen wie das Haus eines
hohen hamaskandeurs getroffen wird der
Mann soll dabei getötet worden sein
Zuspitzung unterdessen im Norden von
Israel an der Grenze zum Libanon israel
hat dort nun eine Sicherheitszone
eingerichtet weil es Raketenbeschuss gab
der Terrororganisation Hisbollah ein
Dorfbewohner wurde dabei
getötet ich würde wärmstens empfehlen
dass die hisbolla sehr genau beobachtet
was mit der Hamas und ihrer Organisation
in Gaza
geschieht sie sollten sehr vorsichtig
sein die Schwelle zu überschreiten in
Tel Aviv trat am Nachmittag zum ersten
Mal die neugebildete Notregierung
zusammen einer demonstrieren ein Zeichen
an die israelische Bevölkerung mit einer
Schweigeminute für die Opfer des
hamaserrors Michael bewerunge für uns in
telaviv wann eine Bodenoffensive erfolgt
es bleibt unklar an welchem Punkt steht
man
jetzt
auf jeden Fall kurz davor und viele
Menschen schauen noch hier in Israel mit
banger Erwartung auf den Beginn dieser
Offensive hinter mir demonstrieren viele
Israelis vor dem
Verteidigungsministerium sie alle haben
Angehörige Geiseln in Gaza und die wären
möglicherweise die ersten Opfer einer
solchen Bodenoffensive im Hintergrund
steht natürlich die große Frage ist
dieser Konflikt in der Lage den gesamten
Nahen Osten in Brand zu stecken wir
haben das gesehen im Norden eskalieren
die Konflikte ich würde zwar immer noch
von drogebärden sprechen vor allem von
Seiten der hzbollah aber diese Droge
wärden eskalieren es gibt immer mehr
Gefechte heute haben zum ersten Mal
Kampfhubschrauber und israelische
Kampfflugzeuge Stellung der Hezbollah
bombardiert der amerikanische
Sicherheitsberater hat heute gesagt er
kann nicht ausschließen dass Iran sich
nicht doch in diesen Konflikt einmischen
will und deswegen ist die sind zwei
flugzeugträgergruppen im Mittelmeer
aufmarschiert um eine klare Ansage an
die hbolla und den Iran zu machen mischt
euch nicht in diesen Konflikt ein denn
sonst würde auch die USA einsteigen
Michael vielen Dank nach Tel
Aviv das Auswärtige Amt hat wegen der
Eskalation im Nahen Osten eine
Reisewarnung ausgesprochen sie gilt für
Israel die gesamten palästinensischen
Gebiete und den Libanon und kann
reisestonnierungen vereinfachen
gleichzeitig flog die Bundeswehr weitere
deutsche Staatsbürger aus erste
Maschinen brachten sie nach wunsdorf in
Niedersachsen Thomas
gonsor nachtlandung in Niedersachsen es
ist der Moment an dem alle an Bord
wissen wir sind in Sicherheit 51
Passagiere im Bauch einer
Transportmaschine Familien Kinder
Erleichterung doch der Schrecken ist
noch nah es war die letzten Tage sehr
beängstigend durch die Raketenangriffe
und dann gab es tächlich auch
Schießereien vor zwei D Tagen und das
war dann so ein Punkt wo wir gesagt
haben wir müssen jetzt raus nun hilft
die Bundeswehr das hatte gedauert andere
Länder schickten Militärmaschinen das
Auswärtige Amt setzte erst auf Linien
und Sonderflüge bis jetzt kamen 3000
deutsche Staatsangehörige zurück oft
nach langem Warten ich war wah
wahnsinnig überrascht dass überhaupt
noch einen Flug bekommen haben weil ich
habe die letzte ganz letzte Woche
probiert weil meine Mama un auch besucht
hat und sie rauszukriegen uns
rauszukriegen wir hatten sehr diffuse
Informationen vom auswärtchen an das war
eigentlich ziemlich unbefredigend und
nicht gut organisiert immerhin am
Nachmittag landete luftwaffenmaschine
Nummer 3 brachte 82 Menschen nach Berlin
weitere Rückholaktionen sollen folgen
von Jordanien wohl auch von telaviv aus
teils über Israels Luftraum während sich
unten der Konflikt zuspitzt
seit Tagen gibt's in Deutschland
Solidaritätsdemonstration für beide
Seiten einige proalästinensische
Versammlung wurden allerdings wegen
antisemitischer und extremistischer
Tendenzen verboten in Berlin kamen am
späten Nachmittag trotz eines solchen
Verbotes rund 1000 Menschen zusammen als
die Polizei die Teilnehmer zum Verlassen
des potzdammer Platzes aufrief kam es zu
Beschimpfungen und
Rangelein Polen wählt heute ein neues
Parlament und behalten die Umfragen
recht könnte die
nationalkonservative Regierungspartei
peace von Minister Präsident morwijetzki
zwar wieder stärkste Kraft werden aber
der einzige denkbare Koalitionspartner
die ultrarechte konfedderationspartei
hat vor der Wahl abgewunken dagegen hat
die
liberalkonservative Bürgerplattform von
Oppositionsführer Tusk die Chance auf
ein Dreierbündnis Andreas küers
berichtet jetzt aus
Warschau als im Warschauer Stimmbezirk
591 Donald Tusk versucht in sein
Wahllokal zu
gelangen sind nicht nur seine Anhänger
erstaunlich siegessicher sondern auch
der
Kandidat ich bin zuversichtlich dass
unser Ergebnis sehr hoch sein
wird mit erheblichen Hoffnungen und
erheblichem Gewimmel geht ein
erbitterteril hasserfüllter Wahlkampf zu
Ende Oppositionsführer Tusk will die
Regierung nicht nur ablösen sondern wie
er sagt auch zur Verantwortung ziehen
für die aushölung der Demokratie die
Regierungspartei stellt ihren
Herausforderer als Handlanger
Deutschlands da der gewisse Herr Tusk
ist ein Befehlsempfänger sagt pischef
Kinski Donald Tusk ist der politische
Ehemann von Angela Merkel sagt
Ministerpräsident bis zum frühen Abend
eine hohe Wahlbeteiligung abzeichnet
wird als leichter Vorteil Tusk gewertet
seine Bürgerplattform braucht
Koalitionspartner die die 8% Hürde
überspringen
müssen ich glaube an die Demokratie ich
denke dass sie bedroht ist und will
Veränderung die peace hat ein gutes
Programm und hat bis jetzt viel getan
für
uns kommt es zum Machtwechsel in
Warschau rufen Tusks Anhänger danke
jemi noch knapp zi Stunden lang hat
Polen die
Wahl so wir sind beim Sport Rudi es hat
geklappt mit der Premiere des neuen
fußballbundestrainers absolut debü
geglückt bei seinem ersten Auftritt als
Fußball buundestrainer konnte sich
Julian nagelsmann über einen deutlichen
Sieg freuen die Nationalmannschaft
gewann mit 3:1 bei Gastgeber USA in
Hartford überzeugte die Mannschaft mit
einem beherzten Auftritt und attraktiver
Spielweise
Euphorie am Teambus vor der Weiterreise
zum mexikospiel natürlich lief noch
nicht alles perfekt doch der neue
Bundestrainer und seine Spieler legten
einen vielversprechenden Start hin K ich
bin auch gerne im Training aber Spiele
sind doch noch mal Tick mehr besonders
ist ja klar hat sich gut angefühlt und
am Ende wenn du gewinnst ist immer noch
mal schöner als wenn du als Verlierer V
Platz gehst nach einem 0 Z1 Rückstand
drehte das Offensivstar deutsche Team
dieses unterhaltsame Spiel dem Ausgleich
durch güoan folgte das 2:1 das Füllkrug
erzielte der dann auch noch das 31 für
musiala auflegte das Debüt des neuen
Bundestrainers macht Hoffnung auch wenn
es vor allem in der Defensive noch viel
zu verbessern
gibt Jess torup wird neuer Trainer beim
FC Augsburg der 3-jährige dne folgt auf
Enrico men von dem sich der FCA
vergangene Woche getrennt hatte seit
mehr als einem Jahr war torup ohne
Verein hatte zuvor den FC Kopenhagen zum
Meistertitel geführt Erfolg für die
deutschen Triathletinnen Anna Haug und
Laura Philipp gewannen bei der Ironman
WM auf Hawaii Silber und Bronze Haug
erreichte nach knapp ateinhalb Stunden
als zweite das Ziel es ist bereits ihre
fünfte wmmedaille mit Platz 3 machte
Philip das deutsche doppelpest perfekt
Weltmeisterin wurde die Britin Lucy
Charles
tren schöne Bilder finde ich auch vielen
Dank Rudi gerne so wir haben noch den
Blick aufs Wetter der geht so im Norden
gibt es viele Wolken vereinzelt etwas
Regen an der Ostsee und im Süden dagegen
häufiger sonnig bei 8 bis
15° ab
21:45 Uhr ein besonderes heute journal
zum Wahlausgang in Polen mit Anne
gellineek und Christian Sivers der live
aus telaviv über den Nahostkonflikt
berichtet